professor X you wanted to see me
Jean Grae I've been wondering have you
as a fellow psychic ever perchance
glanced into my eye
no professor that would be a violation
of trust I completely agree however what
if I were to extend to you an invitation
to peek inside to so you could bear
witness to the knowledge I've amassed
over the years as the world's greatest
psychic really you'd let me do that for
you Jean anything that would be an honor
sir proceed oh my god what the hell was
that I shouldn't have to explain it to
you but obviously I'd like to give you a
good boning oh my god is this what you
brought me in here for was to hit on me
no no no I invited you in here simply to
let you know that you're a very
important member of the x-men thank you
and to invite you to see a very
important x-men's member what fine no I
know what you meant you're a teacher
here students look up to you you I'm a
teacher
good let's go with that let's role play
you are a student and you're failing
young lady if you want this F to be an A
you need to let me ask you in your a how
about you fr you know I have a boyfriend
yes Cyclops the Ray Ban wearing two you
know we're very much in love how are you
because I've seen you many times in the
halls with Wolverine it's complicated
thanks for reading part of your Facebook
page look I get it you're into Wolverine
he's a big hairy dick if you're into big
hairy dicks I can certainly oblige the
carpet does not match the drapes
this is shag down there Oh a shag carpet
because no one's wanted it since the 70s
it's fallen vivacious look I'm clearly
the safest choice in this entire match
Cyclops his glasses fall off while
you're doing it you're toast
Wolverine he prematurely shoots out his
blades cut you up malls you what they
I'm done hearing this you're ready to
act great no I
I love you professor X I want you to
take me right here right now how dare
you don't you ever control me with your
mind again I can control lots of you
with my mind like think of me as a giant
psychic vibrator well you are being a
huge dildo professor X please call me
professor sex you know Oh professor xxx
whatever you prefer remember when they
rated pornos it's never gonna happen
oh come on gene have you ever had sex
with a guy in a wheelchair I can pop a
wheelie a boner and a cherry all at once
okay you've convinced me
really yes great fantastic why don't you
take a peek into my mind for a second
yes you it was dicks and they were
touching it was like the Unrated Magic
Mike you see them on where the foreskin
was over the without the foreskin oh my
god I believe they call that talking and
yes I saw it
holy God I'm sorry Jean Grey I am a
crass obnoxious [ __ ] please accept my
apology thank you I still want to bone
you I didn't make you say that doesn't
make it any less true you know what
professor I quit the x-men wait no Jean
I've crossed the line again and again I
don't know what to say for myself but I
apologize really I can't express that
any more earnestly I am sorry okay your
hair looks great is that okay from one
friend to another yeah that's that's an
okay compliment you know how Rogue has
that white streak in her hair have you
ever wanted one of those because I have
a product that's a hundred percent
organic
come back when your Phoenix you won't be
the only thing that's rising my she gets
it
[Music]